[Música]
para muchos colombia es el mejor aliado
de eeuu así ha sido durante décadas
tanto con demócratas como republicanos
sin embargo los analistas advierten que
eso podría acabar miembros del partido
de gobierno del centro democrático
entraron en campaña apoyando a donald
trump con el silencio del presidente
iván duque el propio trump utilizó a la
comunidad colombiana para sus intereses
en el estado de florida
lo hizo calificando de héroe al
controversial ex presidente álvaro uribe
criticando el acuerdo de paz con las
farc y apelando a la lucha de los dos
países contra el que llaman
castrochavismo y es que las buenas
relaciones entre el uribismo y los
republicanos quedan demostradas en dos
hechos recientes en septiembre
iván duque rompió el consenso de apoyar
un presidente latinoamericano en el
banco interamericano de desarrollo al
votar por claver carone el candidato
estadounidense y en junio diputados
colombianos denunciaron la entrada en el
país de una brigada militar de lucha
contra el narcotráfico estadounidense en
este contexto los demócratas han estado
denunciando que trump había politizado
unas relaciones que siempre habían sido
diplomáticas
siendo dos aliados históricos lo que
pase en eeuu tienen muy pendiente a los
franceses pero con dos presidentes de
personalidad fuerte las relaciones entre
ambos países siempre pasan por una calma
tensa
donald trump se opone al
multilateralismo defendido por el
presidente y manuel macro ni ha sacado a
su país de dos acuerdos internacionales
muy importantes como el acuerdo de irán
el acuerdo nuclear o el acuerdo del
clima de parís y ha prometido que de ser
reelecto va a sacar también a su país de
la otan a donald kan tampoco le ha
temblado la mano a la hora de subir los
impuestos a productos emblemáticos
franceses como el vino y el queso en
represalia por el impuesto que puso
francia a las multinacionales de la
tecnología las famosas en gafas también
ha prometido aumentar los impuestos a
los autos europeos concretamente
alemanes si el viejo continente sigue
subvencionando a la aeronáutica airbus
que es la principal competidora de la
estadounidense boeing según una
publicación económica francesa este país
le conviene económicamente al menos que
gane el demócrata sin embargo no puede
restarle los méritos a donald trump el
haber plantado cara china en su guerra
comercial el mundo dependía
peligrosamente del gigante asiático
y cumplido la promesa de hacer de eeuu
el principal productor de petróleo del
mundo y eso aunque haya significado
bajar el precio del barril
[Música]
la unión europea y la otan han seguido
de muy de cerca de la campaña
presidencial en eeuu y también las
elecciones la unión europea y eeuu han
sido siempre aliados aunque las
relaciones se han tensado desde que
donald trump llegó a la casa blanca
debido sobre todo a cuestiones como el
comercio debido a que estados unidos
aplicó sanciones hace casi tres años al
aluminio y al acero pero que se siguió
ampliando estos aranceles a una serie de
productos que han afectado gravemente
sobre todo al sector agrícola europeo
debido a la disputa entre airbus y
boeing también en el plano internacional
las relaciones también se han tensado
eeuu ha abandonado el pacto nuclear con
irán también el acuerdo de clima de
parís también organizaciones como la
unesco o la oms que han afectado
gravemente a las relaciones
multilaterales aún así la unión europea
insiste que a pesar de que las
relaciones no han sido del todo fluidas
con donald trump eeuu es y siempre será
un aliado tradicional y muy importante
para la unión europea
[Música]